I'm having a great pleasure of
introducing finish Jos our moderator
prayer is the comedian cultureless to
here in New York I should play a really
central role in putting the symposium
together along our colleagues at the
ostrich cultural form and polish
cultural institution which isn't as in a
previous life with an expert on
comparative cultural policy and I think
that that probably will come in handy in
our discussion on this panel thank you
thank you very much I indeed in
introducing this this panel about
unfulfilled promises democracy current
disillusionment I was thinking that we
were speaking about intellectuals and
the world interactions in lost on his
transition and I had two very strong
images one about a drawing my nan
Petrovsky and the drawing shows a huge
crater and inside the crater are three
small people and on the top of the
crater and other three small people and
the three small people on the top say
and here now we will build democracy and
this was drawing a ticket I mean you
never know for comedy in the second
artistic gesture I'm
one of Alexander saw Roman with a very
well-known Romanian documentaries and in
his last dokey fiction called capitalism
our recipe he indeed starts the story by
showing Joshua school coming back to me
after 20 years and discovering that all
his four months ago without the
collaborators and people in her very
well are not very wealthy and by the end
of the field is very very least of all
these kind of three years organization
so I think that if we speak about
democracy and the disillusionment and I
am very happy to introduce here i am
sure three very very complimentary
figures who are participating in in this
panel that i hope to be as strong as the
formal one i will start with the Vietnam
madinia by presenting her and
introducing her her as a professor of
sociology and of Liberal Studies and
also director of the trans regional
center for Democratic studies at The New
School for Social Research for such a
long title that I tried hard to remember
it but I i just had to read it by the
end now as Rita is one of those people
who really through her last book as
activity now just to quote the
photographer a last book performative
democracy is trying to prove in which
way out of apparently disconnected
actors are instrumental and critical
into building a sort of a democratic
climate second participant in the tunnel
is
angelo media-rich who is in fact that an
typical academic is also professor at
the University Constanza but he's also a
film critic and essayist and a writer
and he since long is preoccupied about
the narrative of communist and if i
remember well one of the things he
participated in was a gathering of
articles and of conventions about how
intellectual